so
so
so
so
[Music]
the wolf has been lurking ever since
bigby surprised everyone at the game
awards in 2019 telltale has been keeping
quiet about the development of the wolf
among us too well i'm happy to say that
ends today
right now we're about to see more learn
more and sink our fangs into what's next
for telltale i'm jeff keeley and before
we get to everything else and we've got
a lot of information to share today this
is what you've been waiting for the
first official trailer for the wolf
among us
two
listed here as a private investigator
what does that sort of work entail
depends on the night
most nights it's watching waiting for a
slip up
[Music]
i don't know someone gets greedy someone
gets brave
and that's what you were doing the night
of the incident
yeah
took me weeks to track them down
they didn't care so much as a shadow
till that night
you've been hesitant to share with us
i assume it has something to do with
confidentiality associated with the job
something like that
your boss miss white said things didn't
go as planned
she mentioned that there was some
violence
[Music]
in the moments when you find yourself
losing control
how does the anger manifest itself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow that was a lot to unpack happening
in this new trailer there's a whole
bunch of new fables we're seeing big
bees in looks like anger management in a
new setting and this is all done in a
whole new engine on real engine i have
so many questions here as i'm sure you
guys do but i should probably back up
for a second nine years ago telltale
brought the fables comics to life with
the very first episode of the wolf among
us in october of 2013. nearly a decade
ago it captured gamers imaginations that
fairy tale fables are in fact real and
living in new york city over nine months
bigby's story played out winning the
hearts of gamers with telltale's
signature narrative style in an amazing
comic noir presentation
then unfortunately came the bad news
while a sequel was announced the
original telltale shut down in 2018. a
little over a year later at the game
awards in december of 2019 it was
official telltale was reborn and with it
production of a brand new season of the
wolf among us two was about to start
after that brief teaser at the show
telltale went to work on the wolf among
us two keeping relatively silent until
now
to talk more about why and what's been
happening in the background we've got
telltale ceo jamie ottley and nick
herman from ad hoc to answer some of the
big questions that everyone's been
asking
[Music]
and now they can finally talk about it
to tell us more about the why and what's
been happening in the background we've
got telltale ceo jamie ottley and nick
herman from ad hoc who are co-developing
the game with telltale you guys were a
lot of the folks that worked on the
original season one of the wolf among us
and now for season two everyone has so
many questions based on this trailer but
before we get into the content jamie
let's let's talk about where are we
right now we're actually in the game
right now so this is virtual set this is
godmothers which is a quintessential new
york dive bar but now redone in
beautiful unreal engine one of the
things we're also excited about
especially seeing the trailer it's like
how faithful it is to the original
season one but you know enhanced
graphics but still an amazing story
which is why we're all here for telltale
we love the story and the characters so
nick tell us a bit about the story like
what can you tell us about season two uh
well you know as we saw in the trailer
baby's um in anger management he's um
kind of dealing with a lot of those
issues still
and um you know season two is is you
know still a prequel to the comics but
it takes place about six months after
um season one and kind of like the dead
of winter um and you know people have
seen his new look he's got that he's got
that coat to keep him keep him warm
now you mentioned uh six months between
the end of season one and the start of
season two can you at least tell us a
little bit of what these characters have
been up to in the intervening six months
yeah i mean bigby
as you saw was is now kind of in anger
management but kind of more importantly
he's been suspended from his role as
sheriff and it's like protector of
fabletown yeah um and and snow white you
know at the end of season one snow white
has kind of found herself in this new
role as deputy mayor because you know
this sort of old administration is out
they were corrupt and and you kind of
rooted that out and she's got to fill
those shoes now and she's kind of got
some big ideas on how that's going to
happen but it clashes with bigby's way
of doing things he's not um super uh
personable and and kind of results to
some some some tactics that are less
than uh kosher so there's that there's a
little bit of tension there and now he's
in a new situation where he's not in in
fabletown and he's kind of out there and
that leads him to meet this detective
who um is working on this case that kind
of blurs the lines between uh the fable
and underworld well of course everyone
wants to know which characters which
fables are going to be represented in
this game you know we knew
he would be back but beyond that um what
can you tell us about like which
characters are returning you talked
about
snow obviously like there's you know
certain characters that we would expect
to be there but can you confirm anyone
that that is going to be there is you're
not going to be there can you deny can
you say who's not in the game
we could we could probably talk a little
bit about who else is going to be there
obviously as you said uh big beanstone
will be back reprising their roles um
and then there's some fan favorites like
buffkin uh that'll be there and then
there's some new characters that were
that we're introducing that you'll see
in the trailer um do you have any
favorites from season as you can see
there's some teas of maybe some oz
related things right there are samaz
characters in in the uh game they're a
big addition if they're in the trailer
does that mean they might be in the game
i think we can probably confirm that i
probably
probably just showed you that but that
was that's part of what i think
everyone's loved about this series is so
many of the you know the classic fables
represented and for you guys looking at
this i mean that's part of the fun of
this right is picking where the story is
going to go what i love is that you know
you're not just telling the comics again
so you have a lot of creative
storytelling freedom to sort of come up
with this and that must be i mean part
of the fun of this series right is you
can kind of pull from anything right
yeah and yeah one of the best you know
parts about fables is how they sort of
subvert your expectations of what these
characters are actually like and what
they would be like now um you know
versus the old old sort of fables from
you know over in europe and and now it's
modernized and they've changed they're
maybe maybe they were that person but
now they're not you can look at big bees
yeah classic example um
but yeah and and you know the other sort
of big character that we're introducing
is a detective uh failung she's a nycd
uh new york city police detective who's
basically in the middle of a case that
doesn't quite look right and once big
gets his eyes on it it's like clear oh
like something's leaking out
into the city
um
so like oz characters we talked about
that um they're gonna be in there doing
i don't know how much you can say like
is this are we looking just at like
episode one here in this trailer or is
this kind of across the season or like
what can you tell us the trailer's
pretty focused on episode one to set up
where we're going in this season okay
yeah yeah but i mean if if they're in
the beginning you could probably expect
to see them again a little bit later i
hope so i don't think we would introduce
such
cool characters
never know what happens in episode one
right that's like everything can change
but no that's part of the thing i think
is people know that you're doing it
episodically and everyone i think is
also curious about what the cadence of
this is going to be and how you guys are
developing it you know your telltale is
known for incredible episodic games and
that's one thing we should talk about
like this is the the new telltale and
you're using a new engine which
everyone's really excited about with
unreal so that's is that probably the
biggest shift is like moving to you know
new technology finally uh that's a big
part of it we've developed a lot of
tools to enable content creation kind of
an iteration quickly around unreal
engine
so it really lets us focus on what's
unique to telltale games or in the case
of wolf we needed a specific renderer to
get the lighting and the look correct
and unreal and then
unreal takes a lot of heavy lifting off
of our shoulders right it just works so
we can focus on what we need to do to
make the game work from a gameplay
perspective though can you talk a little
bit about like the telltale style um
it's still the same gameplay style in
terms of you know dialogue and choices
and things like that like is it unreal
does it allow more kind of
game play for a lot of people it
definitely gives us more options but i
mean you know people should you know i
think there's there's a delicate balance
we're gonna have to walk of like you
know taking advantage of all this sort
of new opportunity in space but also
not a third person action game yeah you
know we got to keep it sort of uh rooted
in its foundation and like what people
loved about the first one but there are
definitely going to be some additions
there's going to be some you know we we
took a look at everything and we kind of
assess whether or not it was
intentional or if it was something that
was just the way we had to make it in
you know prior games well and the thing
that we all want is great stories and
great voices and we're really excited
that two of the actors from the original
series are back again as big b and snow
and we're gonna hear from them right now
as promised we've got bigby himself adam
harrington and snow white voiced by
aaron yvette with us today adam aaron
first of all welcome back to the wolf
among us we've waited a decade for uh
this how does it feel for you guys to be
sort of re-entering this world and
bringing these characters to life again
you know to be honest uh even though it
has been nearly a decade it doesn't feel
like re-entering for me and i imagine
aaron might feel the same we became so
close with these characters and spent so
much time with them
uh not to mention all the other work
we've done with telltale
that it becomes more like family the
characters uh the folks at telltale were
working with
um so
it really is it's like coming home
um
but that being said even if if there was
still some problem we're still trying to
get it done the fans are gonna make sure
that it gets done our heads are gonna
roll
yes very high expectations yeah yeah i
mean like adam said
it's like seeing your best friend after
nine years you might have an awkward hug
at the beginning but you fall right back
into that rhythm i mean it's it's in our
hearts
and yeah i'm a player and a fan of the
series too so i'm right with the fans i
am very excited for season two that i
think we all deserve and your characters
i'm sure you were curious about where
the writers were going to take them yeah
in season two we know that this is
six months sort of after the end of
season one so i don't know what you can
say of what you've recorded or what you
know but uh
can you give us a little bit on sort of
you know the where the characters are at
well i can say you can expect some
conflict okay um
yeah the the boss lady here it turns out
is uh put our favorite sheriff on a kind
of a time out so the players will be
able to expect to explore more about
bigby than maybe they were able to in
the first season
and uh really let him sort of branch out
into the bigger world figure out uh what
he thinks is right and wrong what he
thinks is good and bad yeah versus what
snow tells him is good and bad yeah like
i said conflict yeah yeah i think
there's gonna be
a shift in the dynamic between the two
of them i mean in season one
snow is just finding her footing at the
business office and together they
uncover all this corruption which
snow
is driven to do something about but
doesn't quite know how so in season two
we see she's now deputy mayor she's
stepped up she has
power now and i don't think she
she doesn't want to blow it so she
doesn't want to be seen as playing
favorites and that might add some
tension to their relationship god forbid
well i i love that you guys are back
right at it as you were in the season
one and then all these new characters
and we saw hints of
wisdom and other characters coming into
the mix i think it's gonna be fun for
you to see wait do you have any sense of
where where they were going with season
two like when they first told you you've
known for a while obviously it's coming
back but you've all of us have waited a
couple of years since that first tease
in 2019. um do you have any sense of
where this is going
i mean
we when we saw the teaser we just knew
okay so it's coming down yeah this is
actually happening
and there's maybe some conflict between
bigby's natural tendencies you know how
far he has to go to get things done
versus what snow thinks is
allowed um and that maybe they're both
gonna have to test their limits here
yeah definitely especially bigby
apparently because he definitely gets a
slight maybe he's already tested the
limits
you guys are on talking terms and you're
uh yeah yeah in the middle of making
this right now i know you're busy
recording you know putting together all
these you know the amazing dialogue and
all the fun stuff thank god i know but
that's uh that's a great thing for fans
today it's like we saw the trailer the
game looks amazing yeah you guys are in
the studio now working on it and 2023
we're gonna get five new episodes can't
wait
amazing all right well thanks guys we
look forward to uh hearing you uh next
year in the wolf among us season two
yeah it will be worth the wait yeah
i i can't wait for people to play it
all right i'm back here with jamie and
nick uh guys let's talk about the
announcement of this we did it together
back at the game awards in 2019 which
was a big moment and it looked great but
i know at the time you guys had really
put that together there wasn't a game at
all right that was really just sort of
like like almost a teaser asset made
specifically for the show right it was
we were very much in pre-production and
we were trying to stand the company back
up but we also wanted to let our fans
know that we were back and that wolf was
coming so we put that together
specifically for the show as a teaser no
i know that's why people were like oh
can't we see the game's like i think
that's all that exists
coming out of that
so what has happened in the past two
years i think fans you know have
nervously been uh hoping to you know see
more on it and i know we've been talking
over the years and it's taken you guys a
couple years to get to this point what
has that journey been like well we had
quite a bit of work to do to stand the
company back up and just get the basic
things back in place um but most of the
time the creative team's been in
pre-production on wolf among us too yeah
i mean
we had a lot of time um fortunately on
this to kind of really focus on the
story and the creative and make sure
that you know we're set up for success
here and you know i can't really
overstate how important that was for
this um i think you know sort of
telltale games pass and wolf one we're
kind of you know laying the train track
as as the train's going and now we're
able to kind of look at the whole season
and really be you know
do it justice and and make sure that
we're happy with what we have before we
hit do you have the whole as five or so
oh yeah how many uploads do we know how
many episodes we get
or you get five episodes
alright cool so so you sort of thought
you've thought through the arc of the
five yeah how it honestly how it should
be done you know so i mean but we have
everything figured out now and now it's
just about executing and that's where
we're at right now and we saw you know
in the trailer 2023 so you're calling
the ball for for next year not this year
with it where are you at right now in
development well we're in i mean we're
in production we're actively doing
motion capture shoots and and putting
together the the game
um and we haven't named a date in 2023
yet because we'll ship it when it's
bright yeah instead of when we need to
no but it's nice it feels like you know
you've got the stories outlined as you
said now it's really just sort of
piecing that all together and figuring
out the cadence and has there been a lot
of like iteration or rewriting or what's
the process been like um yeah a little
bit but really it's like because we've
had the scripts for so long we've been
able to look at it and our games since
they're so focused on the story and the
characters we're able to kind of play
test it with a script you know it's not
like you necessarily need to have
everything you know in visual form
although that's obviously going to be
another stage of this but um you know
we're yeah we're we're happy with
what we have and we're now just at the
point where we just gotta make it you
know on put it on the screen and and
being episodic i know one of the things
that i guess sometimes was an advantage
back in the day was like you could take
feedback from people on one episode and
inform the next one right or the story
or whatever you're still planning to do
this is episodes but like
more compressed like all together right
yeah we'll release episodically but
we'll be done with all the episodes
before we release the first one so it'll
be a regular kittens uh we're really
after you know giving the audience the
the water cooler moments where they can
discuss what happened last week or the
week prior and and anticipate what's
coming in the next episode interesting
this is interesting you say like you're
gonna effectively have them all finished
and then release them out there so what
does that mean nick in terms of like
cadence is that it's like sounds like
you're talking about a number of weeks
sort of like street streaming shows that
they'll come out and i think so yeah i
don't know if we have it exactly nailed
down just yet but you know i think
iteration was always key at telltale to
make these things work so we're just
taking that iteration and bringing it
you know internal instead of sort of
blasting it out to everyone we kind of
sort of take that process and just make
put in a space where we can you know be
you know make sure that quality is
reliable and we can still get the
feedback from our fans i love that that
was a true season as you said like
watercolor is like hey here's a couple
months where we're gonna get to play all
this together as a community and enjoy
it um one other thing we should talk
about is last year the game awards we
announced another telltale project that
you're working on expanse and you know
sure some fans are like is that going to
impact you know the development of wolf
among us
can you make the outline sort of like
that's a different team right that's
working on that but telltale is still at
the core of it how are you managing the
development of those two things so we
really when when we wanted to restart
telltale creative empowerment was
central to to what we wanted to to have
as a pillar for the company and so uh
nick and the team in ad hoc are leading
the creative efforts on wolf among us
too but we've partnered with dec 9 we're
all fans of the life of strange series
um and so they're uh they're doing the
expanse game so it's a separate team uh
it's really
allowing a new creative voice to tell a
telltale story yeah well it's great that
you have both these things i'm sure many
other things kind of percolating around
telltale and bringing
awesome stories to life i mean i grew up
loving adventure games that's really
what got me into the industry and the
fact that you guys have you know
carrying that torch forward for so many
years and now in this new world with all
this amazing technology and you know the
trailer looks incredible so we can't
wait to uh
play it next year right just a little
bit longer a little longer all right
well thanks guys so much for giving us a
first look at uh the wolf among us
season two we cannot wait to play this
in 2023 uh good luck in the final
stretches of development here anything
else to add before we we wrap this up
yeah uh two things really one uh we
really wanted to say thank you to our
fans and the community um and for the
support that we've enjoyed in getting
this far along we can't wait to share
wolf among us season two with you yeah
um and then uh we have a piece of
character that we're gonna drop that
shows bigby maybe split between the two
worlds that he has to live in and you'll
be able to find that on telltale's
social channel shortly after this
all right well we've got key art we've
got a trailer we've got a date
things are moving in the right direction
we're wealth among us too and thank you
guys i know how hard it is still to make
games work from home and with the
pandemic and everything so uh the fact
that you guys have pulled this together
i know we're all just
waiting with uh great anticipation for
2023 to play so thanks guys uh awesome
stuff all right well while we've been
talking about the long-awaited sequel to
the wolf among us the fables comics it's
based upon is also making a return in
case you missed it fables151 continues
the series this may 20 years after the
first issue hit stands so be sure to
keep an eye out for that as well thanks
so much for joining us today to learn
more about the wolf among us too there
is much more to be done for the game is
ready to launch in 2023 i know that i'm
looking forward to seeing more later
this year once again here's the first
official trailer built entirely in game
giving us our first takes of the wolf
among us season two
listed here as a private investigator
what does that sort of work entail
on the night
most nights it's watching waiting for a
slip up
i don't know someone gets greedy someone
gets brave
and that's what you were doing the night
of the incident
yeah
took me weeks to track them down
they hadn't cast so much as a shadow
till that night
you've been hesitant to share with us
i assume it has something to do with
confidentiality associated with the job
something like that
your boss miss white said things didn't
go as planned
she mentioned that there was some
violence
in the moments when you find yourself
losing control
how does the anger manifest itself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you